we've got more on this story because the
people of parkland Florida are finding
strength in each other after the
staggering loss from the third deadliest
school shooting in US history more than
a thousand people held a candlelight
vigil last night to remember the 17
people shot dead at Marjory Stoneman
Douglas high school we now know the
names of all of the people who died 14
were students three were staff members
killed while trying to save others one
of those students 17-year old Nick
thwart planned to join the University of
Indianapolis swim team next fall another
15 year old Peter Wang he was seen
holding a door open so others could
escape and he was shot Adriana Diaz is
in parkland with more stories of people
lost in this horrible tragedy Adriana
good morning good morning we were here
last night and it was just so moving
there was a sea of candle lights being
held by more than a thousand people and
the grief was palpable and it escalated
when the father of the victim one of the
victims took the stage that's when you
heard people in the crowd start crying I
don't know what I do next my wife is
home we are broken
Fred Guttenberg bared his soul to a
tearful crowd during a candlelight vigil
Thursday night his daughter Jamie was
one of the victims this is impossible my
girl my 14 year old baby I sent her to
school yesterday
she was supposed to be safe earlier in
the day
Warners released 17 balloons and
memories of those killed including
geography teacher Scott beagle he was
engaged to be married and was killed
trying to keep the gunman out of a
classroom he basically saved my life if
it wasn't for him I might not be here
today he will forever be in my heart and
forever be my hero
another hero assistant football coach
Aaron Feist senior tailor Morales wasn't
surprised to hear he shielded students
from gun fire he was always putting
others
so the fact that I heard that he used
his body to protect others that sounds
like something he would 100% do without
hesitation also among the victims senior
joaquin oliver he was born in venezuela
and became a US citizen just last year
14 year old Elena petit helped victims
of Hurricane Emma rebuild and freshman
Gina montalto volunteered as a friend
for kids with special needs what kind of
girl was Gina
she was just sweetest person I know I
never heard her say one bad thing about
anyone no one in the school that died
deserved this I want my friends back I
want the victims back I want all the the
innocent people that are scarred from
this I want their innocence back late
last night we spoke off-camera to the
fiance of that teacher who died saving
students Scott beagle she said that they
were about to start planning their
wedding and that he'd only started
working at this school just this year
she said he was the type of teacher who
could make students believe in
themselves
Nora we love teachers like that hadrian
thank you so much